[Musik]
ich persönlich wünsche mir
konsequentere und strengere wege weil
diese
weiche politik und laissez faire politik
gefällt mir nicht also ich würde eine
kontakt beschränkung mit leichten
kleinen lockdown noch befürworten ich
tue mir schwer damit jetzt wieder einen
kompletten lockdown zu veranlassen also
da würden die leute glauben nicht so gut
drauf reagieren wir haben ein
deutschland warum kann man sich nicht am
tisch sitzen haben die schon und die
parteien vergessen und dann die
bevölkerung denken
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
die rosenheim cops verschieben sich um
circa zehn minuten
das verfassungsgericht hat heute
entschieden die korona notbremse im
frühjahr war rechtens also auch kontakt
beschränkungen ausgangssperren
schulschließungen was folgt daraus für
die politik heute gibt es wieder eine
bundes notbremse beim krisentreffen
heute diskutierten bund und länder über
weitere maßnahmen und einigten sich
zumindest auf die richtung richtung
verschärfung soll es gehen was gilt
bisher wo ein überblick von sven
hendrick an in deutschland bisher ein
flickenteppich bei den corona maßnahmen
kontakt beschränkungen das ziel ist klar
kontakte sollen reduziert werden aber
wie
baden-württemberg will veranstaltungen
im sport und freizeitbereich
einschränken vieles untersagen genauso
sachsen und thüringen bayern macht das
radikal erst ab einer inzidenz von 1000
manch andere länder gehen nicht so weit
in berlin beispielsweise gilt für
veranstaltungen masken pflicht und 2g
zutritt für geimpft und genießen das ist
fast einheitlich
zweig regeln in nahezu allen
bundesländern gilt zweig oder zweig plus
also ein zusätzlicher negativer test für
veranstaltungen gastronomie und auch im
einzelhandel lediglich
schleswig-holstein unterscheidet bis
jetzt den freizeit einrichtungen wie
schwimmbädern gilt zweig im handel
lediglich masten pflicht
was dürfen ungeimpfte auch hier sind die
länder noch uneins so darf sich
beispielsweise in baden württemberg und
im saarland ein ungeimpfte haushalt mit
einer weiteren umgebung von personen
treffen in bayern 5 ungeimpfte aus zwei
haushalten in hamburg 10 zudem gelten
teilweise ausgangssperren ab 22 uhr für
ungeimpfte etwa in thüringen
kroner regeln nach ländergrenzen
in münchen spreche jetzt mit dem
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten markus
söder guten abend schön
abend herr söder sie haben heute gesagt
die richtung stimmt sie haben auch olaf
scholz gelobt ist das gefühlte
machtvakuum in der korona politik damit
beendet
sie haben lange gedrängelt und es war ja
auch der eindruck dass die ampel das
thema etwas wegdrücken will habe ich
fand das war heute trotzdem ein guter
tag nicht nur die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das sehr klar
gesagt habe dass alle maßnahmen auch
eine einheitliches bundesweites vorgehen
rechtens und verfassungsgemäß war
sondern auch die ministerpräsident
konferenz die heute war olaf scholz hat
schon klar gemacht dass er ein
einheitlicher regeln will das bekenntnis
zur allgemeinen impfpflicht sehr gut
dass booster zur chefsache im kanzleramt
mit einem wirklich sehr angesehenen
general und maßnahmen werden im gesamten
land verschärft und das finde ich sehr
gut zumal wenn ich das noch sagen darf
auch sehr gut ist dass in den hotspots
bei uns gehen die zahlen ja gott sei
dank etwas runter aber lange noch nicht
so weit dass es zu einer entwarnung
reicht das in den hotspots auch die
maßnahmen verlängert werden können das
alles ist ein gutes deutsches koma paket
erst am donnerstag beim weiteren treffen
sollen neue maßnahmen beschlossen werden
was ist dann noch besonders umstritten
zunächst einmal war heute ein bisschen
der weg dorthin holprig denn eigentlich
sollte seine normale mpk sein und es
sieht dann ist eine unterrichtung es hat
viele etwas gewundert und verunsichert
trotzdem war die richtung das ergebnis
gutes wird das alles nochmal fixiert es
gibt schon noch ein paar fragen die
offen sind beispielsweise fußball ich
bin der festen überzeugung
weihnachtsmärkte geschlossen werden was
angesichts der hohen infektionsrate
durchaus vertretbar ist auch wenn es
schwer fällt da können nicht
gleichzeitig die stadien voll sein wir
hatten ohnehin mit den niedrigsten
anteil bislang in den dahlien aber wir
wollen in beiden auf jeden fall dass wir
jetzt bis ende des jahres keine fans in
die stadien bringen warum wenn die
weihnachtsmärkte zu sehen dann ist auch
wichtig dass beim fußball das gleiche
gilt wenn es gerade schon angedeutet
einig scheint man sicher zu sein dass
die länder weiter regionale londons in
hotspots verhängen können für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie ausgangs
beschränkungen bundesweit
bundesweit glaube ich würde das jetzt
nicht kommen auch wenn es ja heute
bestätigt wurde vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dass es machbar
ist möglich ist der tenno übrigens ganz
entscheidendes bundesverfassungsgericht
sagt das gemeinwohl geht vor dem
einzelinteresse vor der bequemlichkeit
oder auch der der einzel verantwortung
und das denke ich ist schon ganz wichtig
was wir bei uns haben wir haben eine art
von ausgangs beschränkung wir haben bei
uns schneller als andere diskus clubs
und bars geschlossen und zwar landesweit
auch wenn es schwer fällt dort haben wir
mit die meisten ansteckend verzeichnen
können und in der gastronomie ein
allgemeines sperrstunde mit 22 uhr so
dass man sagen kann ab 22 uhr bewegt
sich nichts mehr und in den hotspots ist
die gastgeber ganz zu deswegen haben wir
glaube ich auch in den letzten tagen
verbesserungen erreichen muss dort
ansetzen wo es war das bringt nicht die
menschen mit unzähligen kleinen
verordnungen ärgern sondern die großen
linien bestimmen und dort ansetzen wo
infektionen und kontakte besonders stark
sind vielen dank markus söder nach
münchen
und in hamburg spreche ich jetzt mit dem
ersten bürgermeister der hansestadt
peter tschentscher grünamt guten abend
ja viel wurde heute über die bundes
notbremse gesprochen das
verfassungsgericht hitze im frühjahr für
rechtens vor allem die unionsgeführten
länder fordern weiter die möglichkeit
wird es dazu kommen ich bin auch froh
dass das bundesverfassungsgericht
klargestellt habe dass diese sehr
wirksamen maßnahmen verfassungsgemäß
sind wir haben sie ja in deutschland
gebraucht wir haben in hamburg die
notbremse sogar drei wochen früher
eingesetzt im frühjahr als alle anderen
länder und haben gespürt wie wirksam
diese instrumente sind gleichwohl sieht
es starke grundrechtseingriffe deswegen
müssen sie dort zum einsatz kommen wo
alle anderen maßnahmen ausgeschöpft sind
und dennoch die institute sehr hoch ist
ja sie haben in hamburg eine niedrigere
instanz und höre im quoten als in bayern
in sachsen hielt sie denn da einen
bundesweiten lockdown für
verhältnismäßig für uns in hamburg haben
wir heute beschlossen dass wir unsere
maßnahmen ausweiten die sind immer 23
früher bevor es dann wirklich nötig ist
wir werden kontakt beschränkungen
einführen wir werden dieses zweig
konzept auch für den einzelhandel jetzt
beschließen das ist etwas was heute alle
länder bekräftigt haben dass wir solche
gemeinsamen regelung für ganz
deutschland jetzt brauchen in den hoch
incidents ländern ohnehin aber jetzt
vorsorglich auch in den ländern die noch
nicht so stark betroffen sind aber
keinen bundesweiten lockdown das ist
nicht das was wir jetzt besprochen haben
sondern es soll jetzt erst einmal wieder
die möglichkeit geben im
infektionsschutzgesetz
auch das zu ermöglichen was bisher noch
nicht vorgesehen war das ist zugesagt
worden und ich glaube dass es gut ist
dass in dieser pandemie bekämpfung der
politik alle instrumente zur verfügung
stehen die nötig sind und die auch
wirksam sind ja also sie haben es gerade
schon gesagt sie haben selbst heute
zweig im einzelhandel angekündigt müssen
sich demnächst auch geimpfte und
getestete auf einschränkungen einstellen
wir wollen unsere maßnahmen so justieren
dass sie auf die betreffen die wirklich
auch geschützt werden müssen das sind
die ungeimpften ein der größte teil der
intensivpatienten sind nicht diejenigen
die nicht frühzeitig auffrischimpfung
bekommen haben sondern es sind die die
keine grundimmunisierung erhalten haben
und die machen die überlastung der
krankenhäuser die sind unser kernthema
der zeit und deswegen sind ja alle
aufgefordert diese impfung anzunehmen
und bis dahin müssen ungeimpfte sehr
starke beschränkungen akzeptieren bei
uns in hamburg in zukunft eben auch im
einzelhandel und bei den persönlichen
privaten zusammenkünften dort soll das
beschränkt seien oft zwei maximal zwei
haushalte so wie wir es auch im frühjahr
für die gesamtbevölkerung schon hatten
vielen dank nach hamburg sehr gerne
ein beschluss heute ein corona
krisenstab wird eingesetzt leiten sollen
generalmajor carsten bräuer das heute
offiziell verkündet
kompetenz in sachen logistik wurde wohl
gesucht nicht zuletzt für die
impfkampagne aber nicht nur dort seit
beginn der pandemie ist die bundeswehr
als helfer in höchster not bereits in
vielen bereichen im einsatz claudia
vogel man über das beispiel traunstein
michael hauptfeldwebel des gebirgs
bataillons 231 aus bad reichenhall hat
die die form gegen die schutzausrüstung
des pflegepersonals auf dieser
intensivstation getauscht er hilft dort
wo dringend unterstützung benötigt wird
im klinikum traunstein hier ringen 15
menschen um ihr leben alle sind in dem
corona virus infiziert michael der
hauptfeldwebel gibt normalerweise
anweisungen schreibt dienstpläne bildet
aus jetzt hilft er wo er noch keine
aufgabe für am patientenbett welche
taschen bei der lagerung unterstützen
bei morschen unterstützen
und den ausscheidungs behälter leeren
für michaela 29 kameraden ist es ein
besonderer kriseneinsatz im landkreis
traunstein ist die inzidenz mit
1066 infizierten besonders hoch auch
hier werden operationen abgesagt schwere
fälle verlegt hilfe benötigt die klinik
mehr denn je
wir sind sehr dankbar dafür unsere
mitarbeiter sind absolut am limit und
darüber hinaus und jede helfende hand
darüber freuen wir uns eigentlich wäre
michael mit seinen kameraden nun bei
übungen im hochgebirge als vorbereitung
für eine übung in nordnorwegen doch auch
seinem chef dem kommandanten der
gebirgsjäger ist klar welche einsatz für
seine soldaten und die gesellschaft
wichtiger ist wir sehen die
notwendigkeit hier zu unterstützen und
haben auch wirklich jedes mal ein
positives feedback gegeben also so dass
sie auch sagen sie können einen beitrag
leisten ein paar kilometer weiter helfen
diese soldaten des
gebirgsjägerbataillons
232 aus bischofswiesen bei der kontakt
nach verfolgung im landratsamt
traunstein
denn auch im landratsamt komme dem
mitarbeiter mit der arbeit nicht mehr
hinterher selbst mit hilfe der
bundeswehr dauert es ein bis zwei tage
bis die kontaktpersonen eines kobe
infizierten informiert werden können
was ist in der pandemie rechtens oder
nicht darüber spreche ich jetzt mit dem
staatsrechtler alexander thiele guten
abend welche bedeutung hat denn der
beschluss des verfassungsgerichts für
die korona politik
ja ich glaube wir haben natürlich ein
anderes pandemie geschieht wir haben
andere varianten aber ich glaube
zentrale aussage des
bundesverfassungsgerichts hat auch heute
noch gültigkeit danach liegt eben die
pandemie bekämpfung zentral in der hand
der politik die dabei einen weiten
beurteilungsspielraum hat also das
grundgesetz steht einer effektiven
bekämpfung der pandemie nicht entgegen
wir aber entschieden wurde er mit der
situation im april 2021 ist das jetzt
eins zu eins auf heute übertragbar wir
haben ja eine deutlich höhere impfquote
ja die frage der impfquote müsste heute
zwingend berücksichtigt werden von den
politischen entscheidungsträgern ich
würde daher sagen dass aktuell
beispielsweise ein lockdown der nicht
differenziert zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften scheinlich nicht mehr zu
halten wäre verfassungsrechtlich weil
sich auch die wissenschaft ja stark
macht vor allen dingen für 2g oder zweig
plus aber auch das steht unter dem
vorbehalt neuer varianten wir wissen ja
nicht wie die neue variante sich mit dem
impfschutz verträgt und was bedeutet der
beschluss heute für schulschließungen
ja auch schulschließung glaube ich sind
extrem schwierig das
bundesverfassungsgericht betont hier ein
recht auf bildung das sich aus dem
grundgesetz ableiten lässt verlangt
daher etwa dass eine notbetreuung
sichergestellt ist aber selbst dann sagt
es dass sich die länder versäumnisse zu
rechnen lassen müssen und dass eine
schulschließung beispielsweise nicht
mehr möglich sein könnte wenn die länder
hier nicht ausreichend für luftfilter
gesorgt haben und zum schluss noch ist
mit dem tag heute die chance für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht gestiegen das ist
ja jetzt allgemein auch gewollt und wird
angestoßen
also allgemein von und auch stolz also
ich glaube wenn man die büsche
wenn man den beschluss liest jedenfalls
glaube ich dass da auch eine allgemeine
impfpflicht zum arsenal gehört dass das
grundgesetz bereitstellt da sind
schwierige abwägungen zu treffen aber
die müssen eben von der politik
getroffen werden die ergebnisse sind vom
grundgesetz nicht vorgegeben anders
gewendet das grundgesetz erlaubt einen
allgemeinen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
verbietet eine allgemeine impfpflicht
nicht verlangt sie auch nicht also die
politik trägt verantwortung so oder so
die politik wird hat die verantwortung
für dein alexander thiele
ja das war unser c im spezial zum
krisentreffen in berlin fort folgt schon
donnerstag mehr informationen dann
später im heute journal dann zu gast
olaf scholz
geht es jetzt weiter mit den rosenheim
cops auf wiedersehen
[Musik]